huh I made the fall this is a miracle
this is America I'm alive chicken I'm
alive I'm so happy I've never been so
happy to be alive isn't that right oh my
god
tastes so good doesn't it still don't
get in my way
Oh what the what nanny what you look
different you have ears where you come
from what what
Sven explain who is this man hey you
can't go in there you can't go in there
that's arranged elaborate that elevator
do not let him in okay good
spend what sets when there's been a new
Minecraft Update what the upgraded isn't
nether that means I have more stuff to
explore I should bring your what I call
him I should bring your forbidden child
with me on the adventure okay I will
hey hey hey yeah hey what are you going
hey stop
get me up oh yeah yeah yeah you stay
here you stay there deep ocean mati
critici-- hi
okay let me just check out what the
damage is last episode we got rid of all
my god oh my god we got rid of Council
of what their sheep
we killed god oh god the meatball no
damage no I can't believe it the
meatball noise Dino meatballs uh-oh
you're free Council of water sheep is
dead tell the King you're free to live
can I eat while
oh yeah that's badass okay here we are
all right
our land is vast and explored we've seen
everything in this game but we have not
checked out the nether update I'm
actually excited it's been a while since
we've seen something new in this game I
think I have everything I need I just
need to say bye to spend some spend then
I usually take you with me on all my
adventures but this time I need to go
without you
I love you I love you too I love you
more I love you wait who the hell are
you oh my god you're your name let's
discuss in Calafat you were a Lolita I
only kissed elaborate am sorry Allah
bless Mulla Mulla belief Allah what in
the world is happening here alright you
better be good you better be good while
I go in nether right I don't want anyone
escaping from your elevator I understand
what carry much spa okay locked in Sven
sorry it's right what are they right I
love you
I'm going I'll take I'll say hi to your
child Alabama oh my god
there he is Alabama on this throne whoa
if they're different sounds in the
nether it does sound different isn't it
I can't tell any difference so far let's
up the render distance so I can see more
Alabama ruler of the underworld what Oh
it's writing a chicken oh my god it's so
cute
take me to your kingdom now or chicken
will die chicken will die oh no oh no oh
no oh no oh no Alabama jokes out Big O
ever do something it was my mistake' it
was my mistake Oh God they don't follow
me through here do they we're cool right
hates when I'm back yeah that was quick
Adventure don't worry about it so I
think they like gold how about that I'll
trade your gold you want gold you like
this all right be cool all right spend
sorry that was quick pop back in to see
you alright don't hurt me all right
don't hurt all right they're hurting me
yes yes follow me mmm yes yes follow me
idiots idiots you're a bunch of idiots
Oh God I don't see any of the Oh God
oh my god good thing I put safety
railing I don't see any of the new stuff
except the pigs don't hurt me I'm
Swedish and I'm nice oh god oh god it's
right there
Alabama what did you do Alabama son is
that you should thank me for protecting
your kingdom
Oh God my whole place is on fire no
whole Alabama do you know how much these
carpet costs it's Gucci my god he's
useful as a useless thing yeah that's
right
got'em all right let's check out the
west or the east whatever it is I'm
going this way my eagle eyes I got 20/20
vision in Minecraft so we're looking for
it there's two new biomes as far as I
know
God stop it stop stop
IKEA bird IKEA bird and one shot one get
like a bird look at that
where is he there it is IKEA bird - he's
my main okay - biomes one of them
it's a forest and the other one I don't
know what it is I think at least oh god
I have not been here a long time II II I
don't like this they're not like this I
can't really see either God
oh whoa calm down
Kyle you don sorry gamers I know this is
gonna freak up the green screen but I
can't why is it so dark
okay that helps I think there's new
materials and stuff would it be smarter
to just fly around you know with the I
feel like that's a sure way to die a
death and I don't like dying deaths I'm
not gonna lie to you guys I'm not gonna
sit here and lie to you guys
I don't like dying Bev's I said it Oh
God
my pickaxe is too strong look at it it's
just demolishing demolitions okay oh
this is not oh I do not like this I do
not like this at all
ow
all right got it I gotta be oh my god I
almost died
sorry I got chicken give me strength
chicken I worship the temple of shaking
and I get rewarded for such bravery
konnichiwa I thought I she bio Madoka me
deskah take me to your leader I can
offer you chicken and gold that's all I
have
Swedish called very fine quality excuse
me
go to do what's a gold in Japanese okay
we're setting out again this is very
very nerve wrecking by the way and I do
not like it okay yeah yeah
if you sing a nice song while you fly it
makes it okay
don't wanna die in the nether but I
wanna find the new biome a whole new God
do not go there Felix she believed us me
by my titties get freezin
where is it where's the new biome have I
been been puzzled I will not get
bamboozled where is it what is that whoa
yeah
welcome do not hurt me I come in peace I
come in pieces many pieces oh okay
whoa if only Alabama was here he would
love it look how pretty
dude I'm coming way to weeb I'm trying
to speak it more so I will learn it
cracker this is a different material
what is it it's it's and what is this
nether wart oh that's a tree what oh my
god
Oh Can I grab these yes shroom lay we're
having some shrooms tonight boys sit
back so you I need the axe for these
maybe no they're all slow what do I use
because there's new material my god oh
my god hey are you peaceful cuz I'm
peaceful I'm peaceful as Frick boy I
don't trust this I wish this man was
here not gonna lie I'm pretty look up
great day it is pretty cool though uh
neurotically I think this is dope when
was the last time we saw a new biome in
Minecraft I say it as if I've been
playing it forever like I've been
waiting so long okay we got grass
crimson roots do I need a hole for these
cuz I read something about hoes in the
new update I don't like the sound they
make it's like strangling a toad or
something yes I will harvest their
materials I come from distant land and I
take your materials ain't nothing
personal kid who knew mushrooms knew
mushrooms
yeah yeah yeah mine mine mine it's all
mine everything
so the axe yeah the axe makes it faster
okay
nice nice okay you should not do that
never dig straight down Felix you should
know this by now oh there are the
villagers hello hello how are you
konnichiwa mina-san how do you say I
come in peace
they must be Japanese oh I don't think
they like me I don't think they like me
I'm gonna go on a limb and say they do
not like me hey I got gold you want gold
you're welcome
you want gold I got gold for everyone
I'm rich I'm rich take it yeah yeah yeah
yeah take the gold yes take the gold and
be pleased yes
oh they fight for me now huh interesting
yeah kill the pigs alright wait oh they
they give the sandstone back Yes No
do not shoot me do not shoot me I will
have to murder you if you shoot me
alright you're dead you're dead and
you're dead and you're dead you're all
dead it's in this ironic you burn up in
the nether huh this is so sad I'm crying
oh not that not the baby don't run away
in fear
Oh God he ran in front of Mara that's so
sad
ooh crying obsidian that's kind of lame
crying crying pathetic
I would never cry in my life crying is
for crying people who cry a lot not me
this is so dope though I wish we could
be friends though I need to look up more
I don't really know what I can do I'll
do it once I grab the materials hey hey
hey hey alright are we cool
I recall you always got to check
people's vibes
I very much like this this is amazing oh
they glow inside the trees did you guys
hear that song are there new monsters I
come in peace do not hurt me I am a
friendly I'm a friendly person and I
will I will inflict damage
there must be something I'm doing wrong
why do they not love me I'm so likeable
and nice maybe there's something about
the gold maybe I need to wear golden
armor and they won't hurt me I am just
like you guys alright so the pigs don't
like me there haha look a dumbass listen
you're weak are we gonna have a problem
here look they don't have a problem with
me anymore I'm wearing gold we're cool
right oh I oh I helped you against the
Piggy's bed we're best friends now hey
hey we're friends friends
8:8 hey what's up I buy your friendship
here I buy your friendship here
like giving me back something yeah I
know it's pretty isn't it yeah you can
see your ugly face in it oh he dropped
he dropped something fire charge where
do you guys live where do you guys sleep
okay you're a little Charlie aren't you
ugly did I just hit Ari they make a real
sounds all right you want gold hey relax
relax there's enough for everyone
alright give me something back though
greedy doing alright give me something
back give me something back you got to
give me something back
give me something yes what it give me I
don't know what he gave me
alright have another one trade me but
dude tell your greedy little child dude
you have two of them snake your snake so
legit all I did was put on some pants
and they're like oh yeah we're cool now
listen listen you're dead you're
pathetic you're pathetic oh sorry sorry
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm not gonna die
like this no I don't think so I will
kill your ancestors and you oh no oh no
oh sorry I'm sorry
Oh God time for Felix to bounce that was
great that was fun wasn't it that was
fun
ow Hey look more gold hi guys
are they drunk nuggets I said nuggets
yeah I did I can say that
okay let's glide back and I shoot them
while I glide
lasagna Oh God pathetic pathetic are we
cool
I recall cuz I will shoot you for an
encore we'd better be cool hey you want
gold I'll be your best friend forever
yeah give me something good give me
something good
potion of fire resistant that's actually
pretty good
thanks man sup sup sup sup sup how long
is that alliance guys I don't want to
hurt you I don't want to hurt you Jesus
yeah kill kill kill we're friends he's
trying to escape he's coming right for
me
are you one train I got gold I come from
the Far West take this and trade me what
you have what you offer
look at that pathetic love beta what it
gave me they keep giving me fire charges
I don't know what they do alright
alright you look rich look at their
greedy little I don't need soul sand
what do you think I'm poor I may be poor
but I'm not pork I'm alright so the
other biome is a forest crimson I think
it's called it's alright I remembered my
coordinates I know how to get home
Alabama will will howl and I'll follow
his howling directions this is really
nerve-racking
Oh God hello found it yes
there's Enderman here there's ender
Slenderman hey I'm innocent I'm innocent
of the Swedish crimes I'm innocent of
the Swedish war crimes i made a saint oh
god do not push me off
I didn't bring my shield wow this one is
so pretty though fluke swamp finally the
real warped roots okay let's get
these as well since they're fairly
similar it seems like what can I
possibly drop the vial
so cool I love this update well done
Mojang ooh spooky sir sounds very spooky
sounds it sounds like there's a dragon
in here or something are there like any
treasures or chests or anything
oh that's tall nanny flan knee what was
that sound
it sounds like I'm eating an apple when
I walk them I'm sure they're gonna add
more cuz this is I'm just playing this
snapshot right now Wow so big that means
they're gonna work on the sky biome next
aren't they that'd be so dope I kind of
want to go home I'm so far away from
home it used to be a problem really if
you want to beat the game to get all the
ender pearls I wonder how this is gonna
change speed running maybe nothing I
have no idea I don't even know how you
speedrun this game anyway I'm not a nerd
dude look how totally goes whoa do this
matt said oh my god oh my god alright I
gotta make it back home somehow does
anyone know which direction back to Bro
town does anyone have the directions
I am scared but I'll make it back in one
please please be back legit you couldn't
do this if you had a bad computer
alright we're getting there
we're getting there I made it back
Alabama I'm rich I traded gold yes for
another rack and crimson roots yes yes
yes your throne will look even prettier
my lord your throne will look even
better than before yes my lord
my Dark Lord alright got a bounce see
you later Alabama later skater
Aled al Alabama Gator I don't all right
I made it back then dude we're rich dude
we're flippin rich so what can I do
warped planks so it's a whole new set of
textures oh oh look at that you're again
I made it again don't talk to him
huh peepee poo-poo what happened
peepee poo-poo Oh what the hell target
what didn't know you can make that
respawn anchor what is that you can set
your spawn points now huh
I can make the tree back at nice what
there's a new armor oh my god there's
another biome we didn't find yet as well
the sole sin oh my god
alright gamers next episode we're gonna
get the nether right armor I'll gotta
get you an armor year again that you're
gonna frickin dick in love spen my boy
we made it back home and we made it safe
but for now and episode smash like if
you enjoyed and if you want more
episodes and I'll be sure to make see
you guys hey door hey hey you know what
big peepees do they play PewDiePie's
pixel ings of course pixel ings is a
creature collecting game I'm the primary
shareholder over a Brazilian players
have downloaded and it's got a perfect
score it's safe to say it's the most
popular game of all time
PewDiePie pixel aims it's awesome deal
with it
deal with it
[Music]
you